hi
in this video i'm going to talk about
cyclin and cyclin-dependent kinases
and watercyclings
so cyclins are basically some proteins
which helps in cell cycle regulation
with their partners cyclin-dependent
kinases as the name suggests
cyclin-dependent kinases are actually
kinase enzymes so their
key role is to phosphorylate downstream
proteins
but something special about these cdks
are that cyclin-dependent kinase can
only phosphorylate its downstream target
proteins when it is bound with its
partner cycling so these
feature is actually
important for
cdks cyclin-dependent kinases
now let's see
from where the cyclin name came from
so the cyclin
is
actually relating to circ cycle
or circle
so
what happens is that
these proteins undergoes a cycle of
synthesis and degradation
during each round of cell cycle which we
would see in details in a moment
so that is why its name is actually
cyclin
because it is produced in a cyclic
manner and also degraded in a cyclic
manner so from here
cyclin name came
and
cyclins
can interact with their specific
cyclin-dependent kinase so for each
cyclin there are specific cdk partners
for them and we would see in a moment
what are the specific
partners for each cyclings and which
cyclins are used
for
which part of the cell cycle
so
if we zoom here
so this diagram shows the cyclin and cdk
activity
and
uh in different type of
cell cycle phases
so as you can see in the g1 phase the
level of g1 cycling gradually increases
and reaches is
its peak at the end of g1
and after the g1
the level of g1 cycling would gradually
decrease
so the cycling activity of g1 cycling is
actually restricted to these
g1 phase after the g1 phase
you won't see any activity
so
the
cycling cycling for g1 phase is only
active during the g1 phase as you can
see in the s phase cycling
it's also produced at the end of g1 or
in the beginning of the s1 and it's
active most active during the s phase
and after the ace phase its level again
falls
and simply for the mitotic
cyclin and for other cyclins these rule
applies so let's see which are the
partner cdks for different kind of
cyclings
so first very important thing is g1
cyclings the most important g1 cycling
is cyclin d especially the cyclin d1
and it's very important and in a
separate video i would be discussing why
these cycling d is very important
and cyclin d has a cdk partner either it
is cdk4
or its cdk6
so
it can bind with cdk4 or 6 and this
whole complex cyclin cdk complex can
perform its job
and after a g1 phase we will talk about
the s phase cyclins the cyclins that are
required for s phase so there are two
basically cyclin and
cdk complexes that are required in s
phase
one
is cyclin
e and cdk2 another is cyclin a and cdk2
and another cyclin is m plus cyclin
which is cyclin b and cdk1 so it is
actually activated during m phase and
it's useful for
the reactions and the the things that
are happening in the m phase of the cell
cycle so cyclin b and cdk2 performs that
kind of job and in a moment we would see
in details
how these type of cyclins are regulated
so let's take an example from cyclin b
and cdk1 so if we zoom over here
so we have our cyclin b remember cyclin
b is actually the
m phase cycling so it's required during
the mitotic phase
and also the mitotic phase cell entry
so the cyclin of b binds with it with
its cdk partner which is cdk1
so
now it's known as cyclin bcdk2 complex
here it's represented as like it
but this complex is not activated all
the time of the cell cycle it's on this
complex whatever you can see here it's
only active during the m phase or the
let g1 and the beginning of the m phase
but other part of the cell cycle you can
see it's not active
it's not active and at the end of g2 and
the beginning of m it's became active
again so how that is regulated
this is our question so actually there
are other type of kinases and
phosphatase which actually regulate the
function of these cyclin syndicate
complexes
one such is cdk activating kinase which
is a actual kinase enzyme which would
actually phosphorylate the cdk
so it turns out that this cac or cdk
activating kinase
phosphorylates the cdk1 at its threonine
61 residue and forms a activating
phosphorylation so it's activating
kinase
but another type of kind is its
inhibitory kinase
they actually phosphorylate but after
phosphorylation the function of the cdk
is abolished so the
inhibitory kind is one of the popular
inhibitory kinase is v1 kinase so we
actually phosphorylates in
threonine 14 and tyrosine 15 residue so
there is a activate activatory
phosphorylation bicac kinase and there
are two inhibitory
phosphorylation by the v1 kinase and
these type of
in normal cases what happen the
inhibitory kinase the the
phosphorylation by inhibitory kinase is
overriding the activatory
phosphorylation in the normal case that
is why what happens in every phase of
the cell cycle the
cyclin bcdk1 complex is not active so
it's only active when uh
it's in the m phase or at the end of the
g2 so what happens at the end of g2 or m
phase so that our cdk1 and cyclin b
complex get activated
so at the end of c2 another key player
is cdc 25 so cdc25 it's actually a
phosphate enzyme
as the name suggests phosphatase would
cleave the phosphate groups and which
phosphate groups would it cleave it
would cleave these inhibitory phosphate
groups and now we have only a
activatory phosphate group over here so
now this
cyclin
b
and
cdk1 complex
is active
and it can perform its job uh
and because it has a activatory
phosphorylation by this cac one kinase
and there is no more
inhibitory phosphorylation present in
these
uh complex
in this uh in this way the cyclin b and
cdk one
uh functions
same type of regulation is valid for
other type of cyclins such as cyclin d
and cdk4
and all other type of cyclins but for
simplicity i have shown you only one
example how a cyclin p and cdk1 which is
actually a m phase cycling is regulated
so
hope you enjoyed the video
please like and subscribe for more video
thank you